on this episode we talk about
outsourcing everyday tasks depth and
width and how I react when somebody asks
for a selfie
[Music]
this
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 178 of
the askgaryvee show it's very exciting
day here at Vayner d-roc you could show
it we'll give him a little we'll give
him a little look on what's going on the
big hair these are the rock are you
these are big hammers the rock I mean
you're rolling with a very small camera
is this making you feel insecure I mean
these are big-ass cameras d-roc you okay
all right India I know you were sick and
shoveled in I'm super excited you
feeling better you excited to be back
yes you missed a show thank you
all right so let's get into that show
India let's go rocking and rolling we're
on a tight schedule now I want to I'm
sorry I want to talk about a couple
things one thank you guys so much for
all the love on dailyvee everybody's
loving that d-roc this is really up to
your brand this through the roof because
of this people really believe that
you've got a little bit of talent now
and I'll be honest with you Stefan in
India I've been talking you've changed
you you now think you're a big deal I'm
just kidding
right is he trying to create like the
expose him a little bit so thank you
guys all for that super excited about
the book the snapchat stuff there's a
lot there's a lot we need to catch up on
I feel like very like I have to go fast
today so like we'll catch up in 179 but
there's a barter page we've got that
going on the snapchat thing we put
together was phenomenal the audio book
is done and in the bag there will be an
audio book if you have a new watching
snapchat on dailyvee and I've enjoyed
all the feedback from so many of you
that are missing the askgaryvee show yes
a lot of you were like oh dailyvee is
now my favorite thing cool but a lot of
momentum for askgaryvee and so just to
make the the the record straight I will
continue to the askgaryvee show I've
just been really busy now the good news
is D Brock's probably gonna travel with
me quite a bit for daily be during the
intensity that is going to be March in
April with the new book and Dirac will
hack doesn't in fact we'll come up with
some side ideas where people can be the
India of the show because you know I
don't think were going to travel India
sorry India alright fine oh dear we got
miking indi a lot of people are asking
for that stuff what do well that's what
you guys are supposed to be doing don't
I know me okay good idea let's get into
show Chase asks why are so many people
worried about their marketing ability
while their product is plain awful well
chase I think this comes down to
something that I call ugly child
syndrome what I mean by that is you know
at some level people are very deep into
their product they've spent time in
years and money developing their product
and they're stuck right like they think
that good marketing or great marketing
can fix that product and service you're
pandering if you've watched me at all
your pandering to me right now because
you know that I love to say even the
greatest marketing of all time is not
gonna fix your [ __ ] product so like I
get it and I agree and I think the
reason that people are in that place is
it's less expensive and seems more
practical to go and fix the marketing
over your product than to scrap your
whole business and start creating a new
charger or a new you know sneaker or a
new shirt like that seems like a reset
whereas whereas great marketing feels
like a renovation and most people want a
patchwork and most people want a quick
fix and it's just human behavior that
it's tough to take a step back and say
let's start all over that's just not a
place where most people want to go or
can they even practically afford to go
so this is a very common problem for a
lot of businesses and if you're in that
spot right now
I think you really have to debate if
you're better off kind of punting going
and getting a job than going into more
debt or getting further along or the
thing I think a lot more about and
something I'll probably pound a lot more
in 2016 which is opportunity costs when
do you cut bait so that you can go on to
do the next part of your life because
squeezing squeezing a raisin for juice
for another year isn't gonna get you
anything
thank you I'm feeling sharp today I feel
really sharp I mean the audiobook these
guys feel really goddamn sharp Christine
asks what is the best way to bring
awareness to your brand when first
starting up steam is I mean have you
watched 175 I mean there's a million
things you can do I mean PR is still a
basic tried-and-true meaning like show
on blogs and be interviewed and show up
on a blab and show up on a periscope and
things you can do without a PR company
and paying them two to five thousand
dollars a year just hack go on you know
I mean this is really like this is
almost tiresome so what's her name
Christine I'm sorry but like this is
like I mean this is literally like hey
Gary recap everything you've been
talking about for nine years I mean I'd
almost rather you just google my name
and get those answers this way but I'll
pander to the context of show I'm a
little bit pissed off at you India for
this question this makes no sense
there's a million things create content
use social networks all this stuff now
doesn't cost money see the reason I love
social media is it's layered on top of
the Internet and it doesn't cost you
money it cost you a talent and time but
it doesn't cost you money like email
HuffPo and say I want to I want to guess
blog okay and then you talk about your
stuff and it's so easy influencer or
send them free product I have no idea
what your product or service is but
there's so many ways to get exposure I
get that I'm good at it but the
blueprint has been absolutely laid out
for so many people its content creation
and it's its content and distribution at
its most basic form content and
distribution the distribution game has
changed so much over the last decade the
youtubes and Facebook's and Twitter's
and snapchats they all work if you know
how to use them it's a tool right like
if I don't know how to use a wrench it's
not valuable to me if you don't know how
to use YouTube it won't be valuable to
you but what you need to do is you need
to figure out how to make them valuable
or hire or partner with somebody that
will make it value both for you but the
ability to get exposure now has never
been easier the problem is that means
everybody's going into that game and it
healed errs the supply and demand of
attention and so now everybody's got an
at-bat and now the cream has to rise to
the top I don't know like that I wasn't
super new India that's different than
perspective something
Andrew Andrew asks what normal tasks do
you outsource for example preparing your
meals doing your laundry etc in order to
enable you to focus on work well I'm out
sourced everything my whole life either
I outsource it or I punted since I was
about in third grade if I didn't think
it was valuable to
to buy the New York Jets I've out
sourced or punted it school could an
outsource it couldn't say hey Brian Chen
real actual person one of my best
friends in the middle school hey Brian
Chen do my homework and take my test
couldn't do that so instead I just took
ass just punted it sorry I'm out
outsourcing you know when I went to
college I was not capable of doing my
own laundry because my mom did
everything for me so I hacked and I mean
this is kind of awkward but like I would
like get girlfriends to do it for me
like I would just like I guess hook up
with girls so they would do my laundry
because there was no other way for me to
do my laundry because to this day as I
sit here in front of you as a 40 year
old man I've never done laundry in my
life now I know you're judging me and I
respect that but I'm judging you because
I'm Way better at business than you are
so like listen it's fair like I look I
think I think that there's uh I mean I
outsource every I don't want do anything
I would never ever ever do anything that
I didn't want to do if I could help it I
don't want to change my tire on the
highway I have because I was stuck but
if there was a new like app called tire
where I could hit it and in three
minutes somebody would be there I would
do that every time I don't want to do
anything that I don't want to do and I
believe everybody's the same way and so
I've worked very hard to try to put
myself in the financial situation to do
things including fixing my weight and my
health because I needed somebody else to
really be full-time for me to get there
and then and then I'm just self-aware
about those things I don't want to I
don't care how you judge me I'm never
doing my laundry
like I get it and I don't think that I'm
right I just think it's my truth
Cory asks I might be the best example of
someone who gets distracted by with
instead of death do you ever have to
regain focus tips
yeah Korea I mean you know you're
talking about like worrying about how
many followers do have and how much
reach you have and not worrying about if
you've positioned yourself to actually
convert on what you want to for me my
religion is depth not width and so it I
don't struggle with that I never care
about how many Twitter followers I have
or how much traffic I have to my website
I'm always thinking about the moment I'm
gonna deal with in about a month which
is you know did I sell books
right did everything lead to that moment
by the way is it March is it February
23rd like telethon great February
23rd get ready we have to film the
commercial for the February 23rd anyway
February 23rd mark your calendar right
now actually actually can we get that on
the calendar app on garyvaynerchuk.com
we need to get that up from what 10:00
a.m. to 6:00 yeah 10:00 a.m. to 6:00
p.m. I'm doing a huge telephone where
people buy eight books and the whole
thing is gonna be huge anyway I need to
refocus on different things not the web
the the width and depth thing I need to
refocus on opportunity costs this is
gonna become my feet you think you're
tired of me talking about snapchat wait
till you hear how much I'm gonna pound
you in 2016 with opportunity costs
because I'm becoming more self-aware
that my misses in my career aren't
necessarily the things I'm doing they're
the things I'm not doing because of the
certain things I'm doing got it so I
think that's what I'm trying to focus
myself on which is putting myself in the
best position to succeed and auditing my
talents and my upside to allocate my
time and my efforts Travis asks do you
lose respect for business people if they
go all fangirl on you want to take pics
etc do you feel respected or used I feel
flattered I mean I don't
I definitely don't disrespect that it's
the same way I react the brain and
Marshall or you know like when you're
into something if you're into you know
the great blessing of my life another
nice thing that happened to me was I'm
in the prime of my career when this
entrepreneurship became something people
wanted to talk about right and so I mean
for the things that I was taught that I
was a loser at from first grade to
twelfth grade has now become the
foundation of people wanting to take
selfies with me on the streets of New
York
I do not disrespect somebody I don't
feel like that first of all you have to
understand how I roll I already think I
have an edge on all of you so there's
nothing to change right if you ask me
for a selfie I don't think like oh now I
got you I think I got you from the get I
think I'm better than everybody in that
weird way when it comes when I put my
business uniform on so I I don't think
it changes my relationship that somebody
wants to do that and I equally feel okay
to do that to a Jets offensive lineman
because that's the thing I'm passionate
and excited about for me the feeling is
very simple I'm flattered I'm humbled I
actually think the people that like me
and are able to get through my facade of
energy and
ego and bravado and actually value my
content are quite smart and probably
have a little bit more EQ and maybe
that's my own ego talking about myself
but the truth is that's how I look at it
and so I'm actually intrigued by my fan
base you know a lot of people are always
like you know a lot of you're like man
you should have more YouTube followers
like more people should know garyvee all
this stuff that you guys are so nice to
me about I'm not so easy to figure out
my friends we talk about this is why I
post on Instagram like what was your
first reaction to me because I want you
guys it's not for me to feel great about
myself I already got that check that box
that's set for life it's for you to see
how other people reacted to learn why
this is all happening I'm a little bit
of a contradiction I'm not so easy to
figure out and so if somebody comes up
to me and says I like your stuff the
things that I default into the quick
rush of emotion the blood that rushes to
my head is like holy crap number two is
like did anybody else see this like that
India say this see how popular I am you
know like number three is huh this
person is interesting they were able to
figure it out why you know those are the
things that tend to rush to my head
great good show good show right yeah
it's funny question of the day who's
gonna win the Super Bowl
and why is the fun one and number two
because I haven't been doing the show
that much and I need Khan comments
they're my oxygen I love your audit on
episode 10 and 11 of the daily V you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]